واكد قائد عسكري في مجموعه ان لدى
بيلاروسيا اليوم قوات ذات قدرات قتاليه
قويه بعد استضافتها عناصر فاجنر واضاف
القائد ان وجود قوه فاجنر على مسافه نحو
100 كيلومتر من كياف يثير قلق النيتو وفي
موسكو وصف الكريم لنا التقارير على ان
نائبه قائد القوات الروسيه في منطقه
العمليه العسكريه كان على علم بخطط مالك
شركه فاغنريكوجن للتمرد المسلح وصفها
بالاشاعات والتكهنات من موسكو تنضم الينا
رانيا دريدي رانيا اذا تداعيات ازمه لم
تنتهي روسيا كيف يتعامل معها
بدايه فيما يتعلق بالاتهامات او ما تم
تناوله في وسائل الاعلام الغربيه بشان
معرفه النائب قائد العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه
بهذا التمرد المسلح الذي اطلقه مالك شركه
فاجنبي
الواضح ان اشار الى ان ذلك ياتي في اطار
الشائعات والتكهنات وان هناك العديد من
الاحاديث والاقاويل التي تتداولها وسائل
الاعلام وهذا التصريح ياتي في اطار هذه
التكهنات مما يتعلق بالتصريحات التي صدرت
اليوم عن احد قاده مجموعه
بالطبع هذا جلال يعني التصريح قد يكون
الابرز منذ التمرد المسلح الذي شهدته
الروسي في الرابع والعشرين من الشهر
الجاري تحدث عن عده نقاط في غايه الاهميه
اولا اشار الى ان حاليا مجموعه فارغنر
تعمل وفقا للمعتاد وفقا للسابق حسب تعبيره
اكد ان جزء من مقاتله سينتقل الى
بيلاروسيا وانه حتى هذه اللحظه هناك
تساؤلات فيما يتعلق بمستقبل عمل شركه
فاجنر على الارض في روسيا تحدث ايضا عن ان
شركه فاغنر ستستمر بعملها بشكل طبيعي
وبشكل هادئ لسيمه وان هناك وجهات جديده
فتحت امام مقاتلي الشركه بالاشاره الى
الوجهه الجديده المتمثله ببيلاروسيا نقطه
اخرى وهي ان وقد شدد عليها هذا المقاتل
هذا القائد الذي اشار لانه حاليا بعد
انتقال المقاتلين مجموعه بيلاروسيا باتت
بيلاروسيا تملك وحده عسكريه هي من اقوى
الوحدات العسكريه في العالم تبع ذلك
بالحديث عن انه
لا يجب ان تكون هناك يعني
اي تكهنات من الممكن حسب تعبيره ان يتم ان
تضطر بغروسيا لمواجهه احداث اخرى جديده
تبع ذلك بالحديث عن ان
الحدود البيلاروسيه
كيف تبعد فقط 100 كيلو متر واشار ايضا الا
انه في حال قررت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
التوجه
وعاصمه كيف من الشمال فانها ستحتاج لحجه
للدخول الى الاراضي البيلاروسيه لتنفيذ
ذلك وهنا بالفعل في موسكو العادي الكثيرون
قراوا ذلك ان على ان ذلك تصريح هو اشاره
الى امكانيه ان تدخل قوات فاجر من الاراضي
البيلاروسيه
من الشمال نحو كيف في حاله اتخذت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه هذا القرار اذا هذا
التصريح هو يعني بالفعل في غايه الاهميه
ولا سيما وان القائد اشار الى انه لا يجب
التسرع باتهام شركه فاغنر بالخيانه ومن ثم
تحدث عما قاله وبالفعل يعني هناك يعني هذه
هذا التصريح يعني يثير الكثير من
التساؤلات فيما يعني فيما يتعلق بمستقبل
فاينر في المنطقه لاسيما في بيلاروسيا
شكرا رانيا في موسكو